If then you have been raised with Christ,
seek the things that are above where Christ is seated at the right hand of God.
Set your minds on things that are above, not on things that are on earth
For you have died and your life is hidden with Christ in God.
When Christ who is your life appears, then you will also appear with him. And,
Well, happy Sunday faith family.
It's always good to be together and to see you and to get to worship together.
The Lord's invited us into his presence. What a gift.
We get to do this together. My name's John. I'm one of the pastors here.
If I haven't met you yet, please come say hello. Love to meet you. Uh,
we've got plenty of other ways you can connect with someone out there or in the
seat back in front of you this fall if you're new.
We're studying through the Apostle Paul's letter to the Colossians,
and we are now into the body of the letter where it's showing us how Christ
above all actually applies in daily life. Last Sunday,
we began pulling this thread of how the philosophies and spiritual powers
were tempting that young church in Colossae away from the gospel of
Christ alone to be their salvation and their hope.
And so Paul reminded them and he reminded us as well that Christ was
and is superior to all of those other rulers and authorities.
No matter if they're material or spiritual, physical or spiritual,
he is over them all. Well,
we see another therefore in verse 16 today.
Remember we saw that last week as a marker, a transitionary word.
And and what we see this today leading us to is where Paul takes another step
in how these people were using these philosophies against the Gentile Christians
in Colossae. He says, here's how it's actually playing out.
Be aware that it wasn't just the powers and the spiritual authorities
that they were facing in the spiritual world.
It was also now we'll see people tempting the believers to
slip into a religious legalistic system rather than the gospel
into making their faith. Jesus plus anything else,
Jesus plus works Jesus plus Judaism,
Jesus plus a ritualistic calendar following Jesus plus
anything. Now that's not just a problem back then.
That's a problem for us just as much as it is today. Like
the idea that we can drift into the same temptation where we add things
onto our faith all the time
instead of relying solely on God's work in our place for our salvation,
for our continuing faith. We rely on all this other stuff,
adding onto it instead of just focusing on the Lord.
And we do that because we want to kind of justify ourselves.
We wanna qualify ourselves and say,
well of course I need to do this and this and this also, right?
Like to feel justified before the Lord. We'll do it that way.
Or we'll do it to disqualify someone else. Well,
they're not doing this, this or that or, or they're not doing these things.
Surely they're not a believer, right? That's what happens all over the place.
As we go beyond the Bible into self-made rules and
regulations, it's dangerous.
We'll see that today in God's word.
And so turn with me to Colossians chapter two again,
Colossians chapter two in the New Testament.
This week will be in verses 16 through 23 of chapter two,
which sets us up really well for next week in chapter three,
where we get even more practical, uh, through the rest of the book. But for now,
verses 16 through 23,
he's gonna focus in to continue this thread we began last week.
I'm gonna read the whole section first and we'll work back through it.
Remember what we saw last week again? 'cause he says therefore in verse 16,
what's he talking about?
He's talking about how Christ is superior to all these other spiritual powers
and worldly principles. Christ is above those.
Verse 16. Therefore,
let no one pass judgment on you in questions of food and drink or with
regard to a festival or a new moon or a Sabbath.
These are a shadow of the things to come,
but the substance belongs to Christ.
Let no one disqualify you insisting on asceticism and worship of angels
going on in detail about visions puffed up without reason by his sensuous mind
and not holding fast to the head from whom the whole body nourished,
knit together through its joints and ligaments grows with a growth that is from
God. If, or you might say, since with Christ,
you died to the elemental spirits of the world.
Why as if you're still alive in the world, do you submit to regulations?
Do not handle, do not taste,
do not touch referring to things that all perish as they're used according to
human precepts and teachings.
These have indeed an appearance of wisdom in promoting self-made religion and
asceticism and severity to the body.
But they are of no value in stopping the indulgence of the flesh.
God, help us to see what you want us to see today. This is your work.
It's your word. We need you Holy Spirit,
to open our hearts and our minds and our eyes to see this
God make us good soil.
That we would receive this your word and it would plant and bear
hundred fold good fruit in our lives.
Teach us, God, we need you. This is confusing. There's hard things.
So God clarify,
make it abundantly clear in our hearts what you want from us and for us today.
In Jesus' authority we pray. Amen.
And so these things I just read were clearly being advocated all around the
church in colossae.
These religious teachers were walking around teaching this stuff and,
and some of those teachers were even passing judgment or it says
disqualifying others. It says there that word means to push out of bounds.
It means to rob of the prize they were,
they were using these practices and these requirements to gauge whether someone
was really a Christian or not. They're building fences and saying, well,
these things are, are proving that you're not a Christian. Well,
notice what these things are. Food, drink, festivals, Sabbath,
these were all very Jewish concepts, right?
And so these false teachers were advocating that a person essentially had to
become Jewish in order to prove their salvation to not be
disqualified from this faith.
But not only that, they went further.
They talked about worshiping angels and asceticism. Now,
that's a really big word. We don't know what that means. So often it,
it's simply a word that means denying yourself pleasure.
So people throughout the centuries have done this where it's, uh, like you,
you don't eat for a long period of time. You don't have a mattress you sleep on.
You don't get a coat when it's cold outside. It's, it's ace practices,
denial of self practices for the sake in their mind of,
of growth spiritually.
And so what we see then we put all this together in colossal,
there was probably some impure form of Judaism.
It was intermingled with some practices that other religions would do in kind of
mishmash together. But it was a form of Judaism nonetheless.
And these religious leaders were advocating that they,
that people needed to go back to the law,
to these ritualistic practices in order to gain some higher form of
spirituality. That's the context.
Paul then says, okay guys, hold up. Let me teach you some things here.
Hey church,
let me remind you of a few truths as you hear all of this stuff.
Here's the first one.
He reminded them that Christ is the fulfillment of the law.
Christ is the fulfillment of the law.
Now, where did I get that from this text? Well,
because so much of this Old Testament language is about the law here,
and it's talking about when or where they could drink this or that,
or wine or not, or,
or even eating laws like no eating pork or shellfish or
even boiling a goat in milk.
Like all those things were questions and laws that they had.
There were laws on festivals, new moons here, Sabbath.
And, and remember those three things were celebrations that were,
were meant to remember something. They were celebrations.
Israel was to have every couple years or every year or month or week to
remember God in some way. But eventually they started great,
but eventually morphed into just ritualistic religious practices that
they did just because they did 'em.
And what would happen is Jewish leaders back then especially, but even today,
would debate applications of all of these laws.
Like I said, it does happen today too. They have to debate whether, uh, uh,
a metal detector is lighting fire on the Sabbath.
They have to figure out the application.
There's debates about cheeseburgers going on right now,
like is that boiling a goat in its mother's metal?
Like have they have to apply all of these things?
And so these leaders would sit around and debate applications of the law.
And what we learned is that some of those leaders were
excluding gentile Christians because those people were not following the
strictest set of rules they could come up with.
They weren't doing all of these things. So they're out.
Now remember,
God's law was given to reflect God's character.
It was given as a covenant set of expectations for
his people, how to respond to him and how to treat one another.
And so it was good, we'll say that again later, but hear me.
It was not intended to be the end game.
God's law was not intended to be the end game set up the covenant
boundaries. But in the law itself,
it was pointing forward to something later,
to something that it was gonna fulfill it.
It was pointing forward to the Messiah.
It was pointing forward to who we know as Christ Jesus.
That's what Romans 10, four says. Christ is, is the end of,
or the culmination of the law for righteousness to everyone who
believes it was waiting for Christ.
In fact, Jesus himself said it this way In Matthew five 17 and 18,
Jesus says, do not think that I've come to abolish the law or the prophets.
I've not come to abolish them, but to fulfill them.
For truly, I say to you, until heaven and earth pass away, not an iota,
not a dot will pass from the law until all is accomplished.
Those were the smallest strokes of a pen in Hebrew and Greek, that those things,
every little piece of it, even the tiniest piece of the law, he says,
will be fulfilled. It'll be accomplished in me. He says,
then he goes on in verse 20. He says, for I tell you,
unless your righteousness exceeds that of the scribes and the Pharisees,
you will never enter the kingdom of heaven.
Now, that's a big uhoh moment for us right there. It should be.
'cause remember who the scribes and Pharisees were, right?
They were the best of the best. They were the the religious Navy Seals.
They did everything right. They were the the to the T,
every little iota and dot.
They were trying to figure out ways that they could build fences around even
that law. So they never even caught close to obeying that law.
They were the righteous of the righteous, you might say.
Yet Jesus, did you hear him?
He says that your righteousness high score must beat theirs.
And when you're playing that arcade game and you get a high score,
theirs was way higher. You gotta beat them.
You've gotta exceed their righteousness. And even further than that,
he went beyond that in the rest of Matthew five,
elevating the law by,
by as he takes six common beliefs and, and teachings that they had at the time.
And he elevates those going further where he applies it to people's hearts,
not just to their actions. You might know them, right? He says,
do not murder is what was commonly taught. But, but he says, I I say to you,
you don't even hate someone in your heart. You shouldn't even hate them.
Not about what you're not doing or not or doing because you can build fences
around that and try not to get close to that. But he's like,
but still it's in your heart. He does it with lust and adultery.
He does it with oaths and divorce and loving your enemies. He says,
it's not just about how you do things out there,
it's about what's even inside of you, whether it's godly or not.
And so when he takes it to that level, right,
there's gotta be something more here that he's talking about fulfilling the law.
Well,
the first way he fulfills the law is that he expands it beyond what it just
says. Like I I just described. He takes it to a deeper level.
It was merely an outline or a skeleton until Jesus showed up.
You might think of it that way, that it was, it was part, it was there,
the structure was it, but it was waiting for its fulfillment.
And he didn't eliminate it.
What he did is he fulfilled it and he just like put skin on it. You might say,
he said this, my life, my thoughts,
my actions is what it looks like to be a
new kingdom citizen,
to be someone who truly does follow God.
That it's about the actions, of course. Like we shouldn't murder,
we shouldn't commit adultery. But it's also about what's inside of you.
It's about your thoughts. It's about your desires. Do you even want to obey God?
That's a sign. 'cause you can keep yourself from doing certain things,
but do you want to do the right thing?
That's how he in one way fulfilled the law by taking it to its
fullest extent, showing us what it really means.
But that brings up a point when you look at the law like that,
man, that should make us feel insufficiency, shouldn't it?
If we're supposed to follow this?
And it's even about my thoughts and my actions, man, I'm so far from that.
There's no way you and I could live that perfectly at all, right?
Even the Pharisees couldn't.
They could build fences around all the obedience to these things,
but they couldn't change their hearts through those things.
So even they couldn't be perfect in these kinds of ways.
And so you should feel insufficient.
I should feel insufficient.
That's why the way Jesus fulfilled the law is not merely by broadening and
expanding it. He also fulfilled the law by perfectly obeying it for us.
He expanded it to the heart, but even his heart was perfect.
It's what Hebrews four talks about. He was tempted like us,
yet he never sinned. Even thoughts, even reactions,
even his demeanor never was sinful.
And so here's what that does.
It makes his death on the cross a sufficient
sacrifice to pay for our insufficiency,
for our sin, our depravity, our turning away from God.
It pays for the price for our sin.
That's what his perfection does. That's just like we saw last week, right?
That that record of debt that is standing against us, that's legal.
That's because we didn't follow the law perfectly.
So we got this rap sheet that's so full. What did he do with it on the cross?
Uh, Colossians two 14. He nailed it to the cross and put it away.
He set it aside by nailing it to the cross.
That's the record of debt that you and I have because we didn't follow the law
perfectly.
So that's good news that he fulfilled the law by living it perfectly for us.
And that sacrifice counts for us if we believe.
But there's also more to that sacrifice.
His death on the cross also then inaugurated the new covenant.
Now that word covenant is, is often interchangeable with the word law.
So you could think old testament, old covenant, old law.
It it's the new covenant, the new law, the New Testament you might say.
And think about the old one,
the old covenant required obedience to the law in order to ensure God's
blessings.
It also said you have these sacrificial systems that you have to go through
daily to cover your failure. That was the old covenant.
But the new covenant changes our hearts through the forgiving blood of Jesus
in our place. It's not about that stuff anymore.
It's what Ezekiel 36 predicted that God circumcised our hearts in
the new covenant.
You remember last week he talked a lot about how circumcision and, and how it's,
it's just a pointing forward to Jesus. It's, it's not really worth anything.
This is what it's about. This circumcision of the heart.
God changing our heart, giving us a new heart, a new spirit,
something the law could never do
yet again. Remember the context.
The colossian Christians were being tempted to go back to at least some
of the requirements of the law in an effort to ensure that they were God's
people. They said,
certainly there's gotta be more to this right grace alone, Christ alone. No,
there's gotta be, I gotta do these things too, right?
Surely that 'cause that's in our nature, isn't it? We wanna try to create,
we wanna try to, to prove and to earn.
That's just in us as sinful humans.
It's kinda like when Peter went to Antioch.
When he went to Antioch,
he began drifting back into Judaism because he was afraid of persecution from
the Jews. And it's this example right here.
And this is the way Paul responded to Peter in Galatians two.
Peter's name was also CFUs. So, so know that he's talking about Peter.
But when CFUs came to Antioch, I,
Paul opposed him to his face because he stood condemned
for before certain men came from James, meaning Jews.
Peter was eating with the Gentiles. But when they came,
he drew back and separated himself fearing the circumcision party the Jews
and the rest of the Jews acted hypocritically along with him so that even
Barnabas was led astray by their hypocrisy.
But when I,
Paul saw that their conduct was not in step with the truth of the gospel,
meaning pulling away from that acting differently because of Jews around you was
not in step with the gospel. I said to fuss before them all,
if you though a Jew live like a gentile, meaning, Hey Peter,
you don't actually live like a Jew all the time,
just whenever those guys are around. If you don't live like a Gentile,
if you live like a Gentile, not like a Jew,
how can you force the Gentiles to live like Jews?
We're Jews by birth, not Gentile sinners.
Yet we know a person is not justified by works of the law,
but through faith in Jesus Christ.
So we believe in Christ Jesus in order to be justified by faith in Christ,
not by works of the law. Because by works of the law, no one will be justified.
You can't earn it. You can't keep it.
No one will be justified made right before God by works of the law. So Peter,
why are you drifting back into it? That's why He Peter,
why Paul says here in Colossians two that Christ is the fulfillment of the law.
That you don't have to go back 'cause Christ did it for you.
And so that's the question again, I said it earlier,
does that mean that God's law is bad? If it's fulfilled?
Do we just kind of throw it away even?
Was it even good to begin with? Well yes,
because it shows God's character.
Because we see moral requirements repeated in the New Testament.
So it's affirming that it's good.
Even some of the civil and material stuff can apply to us. Yes.
But as we look at the law, we cannot think anything.
But Galatians two 16, by the works of the law, no one will be justified.
Meaning it's not salvific, it doesn't save you in any way.
We can't keep it like that. You can't earn salvation through it.
You can't keep salvation through it.
You also shouldn't disqualify someone because of it, right?
It's not about that anymore.
We follow Christ now who takes the law higher and
fulfills it for us. That's our law now is Christ.
And that's what Paul shared next,
that not only is Christ the fulfillment of the law,
he's also the substance of the law's shadows.
That's the next part here. Christ is the substance of the shadows.
Back in Colossians two, that's verse 17 explicitly right? Look at it.
These all the, the law stuff,
these are a shadow of the things to come,
but the substance belongs to Christ.
Think about it.
There's not a shadow without a figure or an object to cast the shadow, right?
So that's the idea is the shadow comes from someone something.
And so that's again, just like the law,
it was not intended to be the end game here. All the ritualistic practices,
all those religious things that were mentioned in the Old Testament law,
they were also not intended to be the end game.
The food and drink laws in the Old Testament merely a shadow of the substance of
Christ.
The festivals all over the Old Testament, even more clearly,
point to Christ. And just think of the Passover.
The Passover instituted because on the night that they were, uh,
that Israel was freed from the slavery of Egypt,
God miraculously set it all up, did it all. But that night he told them,
here's a meal you're going to eat and you're gonna remember me by as you go
forward. But here what it's about, you need to to kill a lamb,
a spotless lamb.
And you take that lamb's blood and you paint it on the doorframe of your house
so that when death passes by, it passes over your house,
that that lamb died for you. And so you don't have to die.
Is that not the gospel in Egypt,
right? That that's a picture,
a shadow of the substance of Christ
in the Sabbath. He mentions here in Colossians two, it was a Sabbath.
The Sabbath was one day a week that Israel was supposed to stop working
and trust God for his provision.
That was a massive marker in the world around them that nobody else did that
everybody else worked. Seven days kind of just drove themselves into the ground.
They said No six days we're gonna take one day off to remember God and trust
God. Even that points us forward to what?
Full rest in Christ, that he is our Sabbath rest, that we have eternal rest,
that we don't have to work anymore. He's given it to us.
See, these are, these are shadows of the substance.
Even the tabernacle, the temple, the presence of God in a location.
You even think of the sacrificial system in the Old Testament where they had to
kill these animals certain ways and certain times all of that
shadows pointing to the substance of Christ.
Now I wanna be clear about something here. In saying all this, Paul or I,
we are not saying that Christianity has nothing to do with
Judaism. 'cause that can be it. We're just gonna cut it all off.
And it's just all about like that's heresy throughout the ages.
It's happened that way. We're gonna just use the New Testament only. Well,
no New Testament uses the Old Testament all the time.
So we're not saying it has nothing to do with Judaism. In reality,
Christianity is the fulfillment of Judaism
because it was an old covenant. Now it's a new covenant, a new age.
And that new covenant, the new age,
does not need the cultural practices
of, of Israel that was meant to be distinct,
meant to be monocultural. Everybody kinda looks the same, acts the same lives,
the same as a distinct marker from the rest of the world.
And that's what the law was meant to keep, to maintain.
We don't need those anymore because we are a worldwide family
now that supersedes location and time in Christ.
And so those things are not what we're about anymore.
We have a new covenant that covenants in Jesus who is the standard,
the fulfillment of the law. So we follow Christ. Now,
we don't follow those things anymore.
We are unified around the Messiah as our identity.
Not all these external practices,
not anything that we could come up with on our own.
Nothing that we would layer on top of our faith. No,
our identity is the Messiah. He's the marker.
His Holy Spirit in us as our brand, our our identity marker.
It's him not these other things.
Again, that's why Paul argued so heavily that Christians do not need to go back
to Judaism or they don't need to go back to anything else that we could come up
with to complete quote unquote our faith. No.
All those things are copies of the real thing.
I read it this way this week,
don't lose the substance by grasping at the shadows.
We do that, whether it's Judaism or anything else,
we grasp at shadows instead of grasping at the substance of Christ.
So he fulfills the law. He's the substance that the shadows were pointing to.
But there's one more piece of the puzzle here. It's the end of verse 23
here in Colossians two. It's what these shadowy things he's talking about,
it says that they are of no value in stopping the indulgence
of the flesh. That your flesh wants to do certain things.
Those things cannot stop it. What things? Verse 20
again, I said, it says, if with Christ,
that's really a condition that you already have. It assumes you have.
So you might say, since with Christ,
you died to the elemental spirits of the world.
Why as if you're still alive in the world,
do you submit to to regulations like do not handle, do not taste,
do not touch according to human precepts and teachings.
These have indeed an appearance of wisdom promoting self-made religion,
asceticism severity to the body.
But they are of no value in stopping the indulgence of the flesh.
So these things that can't help you stop sinning.
Like that's what people wanted.
They wanted us inherent in each one of us I think is this feeling of, yeah,
that's, that's wrong. Maybe we don't see everything as wrong,
but but there's a sense like, yeah, I shouldn't do that. There's kind of this,
this impression of God written on our hearts like, yeah, I shouldn't do that.
It's gonna hurt me, hurt somebody else. Okay?
And so there's a desire to stop sinning. But these things,
human made regulations, precepts, teachings, self-made religion,
denial of pleasures.
These are the things Paul says here are of no value in keeping
you from those thoughts and actions. Your sinful flesh wants to do, no value.
Zero. Now why did Paul even have to say that?
Why did he just come outta nowhere and say all these regulations?
Because there were teachers in colos saying who were promoting extra rules
and requirements, again, probably Jewish in nature. They're saying,
here's what you need to do if you want to stop sinning.
And they gave these lists, even that that do not handle taste, touch thing.
That's probably a slogan somewhere in Colossae.
They might have put it on the wall. Uh, and like, here, here's what you do.
Here's the answer. You wanna stop sinning? Don't touch that, don't handle that,
don't like, that's what they were saying.
These were probably the same people, by the way,
who claimed to have these higher experiences with angels where they were in this
spiritual state because they're so holy.
And they got this experience with an angel and he told them certain things that
they need to know that they need to tell everybody else to do.
And so what they would do is they'd walk around kinda high and mighty like,
guys,
I have experienced this angelic vision and you need to listen to me
because I have a deeper version of Christianity that nobody else has had ever
before. First of all,
be really careful if somebody says that nobody's ever thought this way before,
Ooh. Like probably shouldn't. You know, that's what they were saying.
And these colossian Christians were being tempted to say, well,
maybe they do have legitimacy. Maybe I do need to listen to that.
Maybe I do need to apply what they're saying. Maybe I shouldn't touch that.
Maybe I shouldn't handle that. And they're going through that.
That's why Paul would say that. And look at how he responded to 'em. I mean,
look at verse 18. Let no one disqualify you.
Insisting on asceticism and worship of angels going on detail about visions
like the puffed up without reason by his sinuous mind. Like there's,
he's saying, guys, it's worthless. They're prideful, they're selfish.
Stop listening to them. There's, they have nothing to tell you
because verse 19, he says, they're out of line. They're adding onto the gospel.
They're not holding fast to Christ the head of the church.
They're not holding fast to the gospel. They're adding on. It's unnecessary.
Don't listen to them. So what he says, instead,
if you really do wanna stop sinning, if you wanna stop indulging your flesh,
here's what you do.
You trust Christ to be the source of your transformation.
That's what he says here.
Christ is actually the source of that transformation you want.
Lemme explain how we get to that look in verse 20,
Paul says, if you believe then when Christ died, all your sin died with him.
When Christ was nailed on that cross.
If you have repented and believed in Jesus, your sin died too.
And then when he died, verse 20 says,
you also died to the elemental spirits of the world,
to these worldly philosophies,
these worldly principles that go against Christ or add onto Christ. He says,
you died to that. It's dead to you.
That's why you don't have to fall back into it. Because we saw last week,
Christ in his death has already triumphed over all of those things.
You don't have to go back to that because they're dead.
You're dead to them. Not only are you dead or they're dead,
you're also a new creation. Now
he's made you a new creation. So when he, when he says this, Paul's like, guys,
those things are dead to you. You're a new creation now.
So why are you acting like you're not?
Why are you acting like you're still alive to that stuff?
Like that stuff's controlling. No, you're new. You're dead to that.
You're a new creation.
Now why are you still acting like you're alive to all those human made
traditions? All those things that you're trusting in to change you. Why?
Why are you being so violent with your body? By the way,
this has happened throughout the centuries. Monks, especially out in the desert,
they would whip themselves when they had a negative thought to try to train
themselves. They didn't sin anymore. I
had a seminary professor first week we we're even there.
He looks at us and he says, Hey, you guys need to take your tv,
go in the backyard, dig a hole and bury it. And we're all looking at him like,
what? What are you talking about?
And he's saying that because it's such a temptation that that's how radical
you need to be.
Is that not the same thing we just read here?
Like is it sinful to have a television?
Can you use a television for sinful purposes? Absolutely you can.
But it's sinful to have a television that's do not handle, do not taste,
do not touch, right? That's the same kind of idea here.
It's not about that anymore.
'cause Galatians five one reminds us,
it is for freedom that Christ has set us free.
So don't submit again to a yoke of slavery.
And what he's talking about there is submitting again to human made rules and
regulations, to following the law as your source of transformation.
That's what he's talking about. Don't get trapped again.
Don't get trapped by the law.
Don't get trapped by what people are telling you to do or not do.
'cause remember, those things cannot change you.
We all drift to that. We think, well this is gonna change me.
This is gonna change me. No,
only Christ can change you through the spirit for the glory of the Father.
That's what Hebrews ten one says,
explicitly listen for the same kind language for sense.
The law has but a shadow of the good things to come instead of the true
form of those realities.
It can never by the same sacrifice continually offered every year make perfect
those who draw near.
It's a shadow so it can never make you perfect if you come near to it.
Only Christ can.
At the first church, I pastored out of seminary out in Weatherford, Oklahoma.
We began having a lot of young families come.
And so we were gonna put in a playground like we should.
And so we looked around and the perfect place was right behind our church
building out there as a great area for it. But there was a big problem.
There was a massive sand plumb bush out there that was about 50 feet by 20
feet, 10 feet tall.
So we wanted to put it out there.
The problem was we had to get rid of that thing first. So what do we have to do?
Well first we had to cut back branches so we could even get to the trunk of the
tree.
They cut through for hours these spines and sharp,
it was terrible, but cut it back enough to get to the trunk.
But what happens if we would just leave it cut back to the trunk like that?
What happens next? Branches grow right back.
So what did we need to do? We need to get to the root of the tree.
Now hear this, we did have to cut the branches back to get to the root, right?
We had to cut up a huge section of it so we get the backhoe in there and dig it
out because it took a huge hole to get that thing outta there.
But we had to cut branches. But the point was not cutting the branches.
The point was we had to get that root outta there.
Is that not the same thing we're talking about here? You can.
You can cut branches back in your life all you want, any self-made religion,
all these things that we're talking about this,
this severity to the body and and punishing yourself and and all that.
That's just cutting away branches. You can put the guard on your phone,
you can get rid of your tv, you can do whatever.
Those are just cutting away the branches.
They may seem like they work and they might for a season,
but on their own, they really don't. In the end,
the only thing that will actually work to change this indulgence of the flesh
to a desire for God is what God alone can do.
It's what Galatians six 15 says. Just like last week,
neither circumcision nor uncircumcision counts for anything.
Meaning you can do all the things you wanna do or not do all the actions or not
do the actions. What counts it says is a new creation.
Those things don't count. What counts is a new creation.
You gotta get to the root of the problem in your life
and that's the problem. The problem is your sinful heart.
It's not that you have a TV or you don't.
It's not that you have all these things or you're doing these things or not.
It's that your heart is still sinful.
It's it's second Corinthians five 17. Therefore, if anyone is in Christ,
he is a new creation. The old has passed away,
died and the new has come. Galatians two 20,
I've been crucified. I've died to myself with Christ. So I no longer live,
but Christ lives in me. Meaning I have died.
I'm a new creation. And Christ,
the fulfillment of the law is who's living this out through me.
That's what changes your heart.
Now,
I know self-regulations and practices can be good and helpful,
right?
You shouldn't probably have this temptation sitting right in front of you.
You should probably get rid of it. Yes.
But you cannot do those things divorced from the source of true
transformation on their own.
They won't work tied to Christ.
Absolutely they can.
The only one who can truly change your heart is Christ
making you a new creation.
Listen,
if you're not a believer and you're just here 'cause your mom made you come,
you can try as hard as you want. You can want to stop sinning.
You can't
because that root is still bad.
And so you need a new root. You need a new heart.
And that comes through dying to self, turning from your sin,
turning to Jesus as your salvation.
But listen, believer, you need to hear this just as much.
If you have given your life to Christ and his life,
death and resurrection is your hope forever and ever. And you've said Jesus,
you are my Lord and savior. Know this.
Don't deny this. Don't. Don't live any other way.
The Holy Spirit has made you a new creation.
You are spiritually alive now. You don't have to go back.
You don't have to wait anymore. You don't have to fall into that stuff anymore.
So don't let anyone tempt you to fall back into that stuff.
Don't let anyone tempt you to,
to build fences around your life and and dead legalism as the way you can keep
your salvation. It's about Christ.
Don't let anybody suck you into that. Let him change you. And then this.
Don't let your sin reign in your mortal body anymore.
Because remember what happened when Christ died. Your sin died too.
So you don't have to sin anymore. The root is good.
Now you have the ability in Christ to choose right, to choose good.
So live in that.
Live in that reality that you are spiritually alive to him and
you're dead to all those things. Think about the worst insult.
You can give somebody the worst.
You look at somebody in their face and you say, you're dead to me.
Tell that to your sin. Tell that to your past,
to your shame, to your whatever else, to these, these temptations,
to keep going back to the law and the ritual saying, no, you're dead to me.
I follow Christ. Christ is in me the hope of glory. I have everything I need,
so I don't need you anymore.
That's the good news that he does what the law could never do.
He does what those shadowy religious practices could never do.
He fulfills all of it.
So trust him with it and walk in his freedom like that.